Senate Republicans say judge neil
Gorsuch will be confirmed as a Supreme
Court justice this week one way or
another the judiciary committee votes
this morning it's expected to send the
nomination to the full Senate Gorsuch
need 60 votes including 8 from Democrats
to overcome a likely filibuster now if
he doesn't get them Republican leader
Mitch McConnell says he will change the
Senate rules to eliminate the filibuster
option look what I'm telling you is that
judge Gossage is going to be confirmed
the way in which that occurs is in the
hands of the Democratic minority jan
crawford is on Capitol Hill Jan good
morning good morning Nora so president
Trump pick judge course because he was
seen as a solid judicial conservative
but who would also be confirmable but at
this point Democrats are vowing to vote
no and they're threatening a filibuster
that would mean Republicans would need
eight Democrats to break ranks and join
them to stop it and right now they've
only got three senators Donnelly height
camp and mansion there are still eight
Democrats undecided on the filibuster
but Senate Majority Leader Chuck Schumer
says his party is digging in courses
will not reach that 60-vote margin so
Republicans are threatening to go
nuclear they would change the Senate
rules to do away with filibusters and
confirm Gorsuch with a simple majority
now some senior Republicans are
reluctant to change those long-standing
Senate rules and there's been some talk
of a deal where Democrats would agree to
confirm Gorsuch if Republicans promise
to keep the filibuster in place for the
next nomination now that vacancy is
expected to be even more controversial
because president Trump's next pick
could actually change the balance of the
court further to the right Charlie thank
you very much Jan